[Music]
this machine is the treadmill you can
attach the emergency clip to the bottom
of your T-shirt and then press the quick
start button to get started you can
increase the speed with the yellow tab
on the screen by pressing the plus
button and the speed is shown there
you can also change the ascent of the
Machine by pressing the blue arrow as
shown there
it is important to maintain a good
posture whilst working on the treadmill
following Heel To Toe
the duration of your workout is shown
here
to end the experience on the treadmill
you will press the red button on the
screen where it displays stop and cancel
it will then show you a summary of your
workout you will unclip the emergency
stop button and then Dismount the
treadmill
[Music]